>> ARE MEN MORE DISTURBED WHEN
THEY GET KICKED TO THE CURB?
IS IT TIME TO LOSE THE NOTION
THAT HEARTBROKEN MEN DON'T SHOW
EMOTION?
A NEW BRITISH STUDY CLAIMS THAT
MEN EXPERIENCE MORE EMOTIONAL
PAIN AND HEARTACHE THAN WOMEN
AFTER A BREAKUP OR AS THE BRITS
LIKE TO CALL IT, BOBBY IN YOUR -
- YOU BLIMEY WANKER.
WHAT?
SOUNDED BRITISH.
RESEARCHERS USE SAID AN
ANONYMOUS ONLINE FORUM, THE ONLY
KIND I USE, TO STUDY 200,000
POSTINGS ABOUT COUPLES
RELATIONSHIP ISSUES.
THE NUMBER ONE PROBLEM?  WHEN
THE GUY ISN'T NAMED GREG.
THE SECOND, SOMETHING CALLED
COMMUNICATION.
THE KEY FINDING WAS MEN WERE
MORE LIKELY TO OPEN UP ABOUT THE
PAIN OF ENDING A RELATIONSHIP
THAN WOMEN USING WORDS LIKE
REGRET AND CRY AND HEARTBROKEN.
ONE WAY TO GET OVER IT, WATCHING
THE NEW BRITISH DATING SHOW, THE
LOVE TRAP, OR AS I LIKE TO CALL
IT BANGERS AND MASH.
>> DAVID, WHO DO YOU THINK DEIS
A LOVE TRAP?
[HEART THUMPING]
>> SHERIE.
>> OH, GOD.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC]
>> IF ONLY IT WERE THAT EASY;
RIGHT?
SO I GUESS WE FIGURED OUT WHAT
THEY PUT IN BLOOD PUDDING.
THAT'S A BRITISH DELICACY.
FRANKLY THIS LITTLE STUDY DIDN'T
ACCOUNT FOR WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
TWO BROHEIMS BREAK UP.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> HORRIBLE NEWS I WAS ONLY ABLE
TO SCORE TWO TICKETS TO THE
LEOPARD ON SATURDAY AND I'M
TAKING KYLE.
>> WE ARE BROS, BUT HE'S GOT A
2017 WRANGLER SAHARA WE CAN TAKE
THE TOP OFF AND BLAST TUNES AND
HIS BROTHER'S THE MATRE-D AT
P.F. CHANG'S.
IT'S KYLE, HE CAN'T MAKE IT.
WILL YOU GO WITH ME?
>> POUR SOME SUGAR ON ME,
BRONAMETH, LET'S DO THIS.
>> THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
I TEARED UP, JAMIE.
YOU SEEM LIKE AN EMOTIONAL GUY.
YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE HAD
RELATIONSHIPS.
YOU CHILDREN.
>> YEAH.
>> I HAVE, YEAH.
I WISH I HAD THAT LOVE TRAP
THING FOR WHEN I HAD GOTTEN
DIVORCED.
IT WOULD HAVE JUST BEEN SO MUCH
EASIER BECAUSE AFTER WE DID IT
SHE SAID A BUNCH OF STUFF.
I FELT LIKE I WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
TO HEAR IT IF SHE'S DOWN IN THE
THING.
HEY, BY THE WAY.
>> YES.
>> UM, SOME RELATIONSHIPS AREN'T
MEANT TO LAST AND IT'S OKAY.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHEN I GOT DIVORCED I THINK
IT WAS ONE OF THOSE - - HERE'S A
WAY TO KNOW IF YOU SHOULD GET
DIVORCED.
IF WHEN PEOPLE START TELLING YOU
NEGATIVE THINGS ABOUT DIVORCE
AND NONE OF IT SOUNDS THAT BAD
TO YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
MY FRIEND GOES YOU CAN'T GET
DIVORCED YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
MOVE OUT AND GET YOUR OWN PLACE,
AND I'M LIKE WHEN IS THE SOONEST
WE COULD DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SEE YOUR KIDS ON THE WEEKENDS?
WHEN IS THE SOONEST WE CAN DO
THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO TAKE THESE KIDS
TO SCHOOL.
I THOUGHT THERE WAS SOMETHING
WRONG WITH ME AT ONE POINT.
NOT WRONG WITH ME, BUT I LIVE IN
ALASKA, A LOT OF MAN MANLY MEN,
AND THAT'S NOT ME AT ALL.
I WENT TO THE DOCTOR, I'M NOT
JOKING AT ALL, AND I GO COULD
YOU TEST SOMETHING LIKE
TESTOSTERONE, I FEEL LIKE THINGS
HIT ME HARDER, I CRY IN THE
MIDDLE OF GREETING CARDS.
HE GOES YEAH, WE DO SOME TESTS
AND HE GOES WE DID YOUR
TESTOSTERONE AND WE TESTED STUFF
I'M GLAD YOU CAME IN, IT TURNS
OUT YOU ARE WHAT'S CALLED A HUGE
WO, SY.  AND AND YO THAT'S
RIDICULOUS,.
THERE'S FLOOR Y WAY THAT'S AN
ACTUAL DIAGNOSIS.
AND HE GOES OKAY, YOU GOT ME
IT'S NOT AN ACTUAL DIAGNOSIS BUT
I KNOW I COULD CALL YOU THAT AND
YOU WOULDN'T DO ANYTHING BASED
ON THE TESTING.
[APPLAUSE]
>> SO GOOD.
ALL RIGHT, KAT, YOU'RE A GIRL.
>> SURE AM.
I FIND IT DEVASTATING.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH, BECAUSE I THOUGHT THE
REASON THAT GUYS WOULD GET SO
UPSET AND WANT TO GET BACK
TOGETHER AFTER WE BROKE UP WAS
BECAUSE I WAS SO SPECIAL.
APPARENTLY NOT.
>> NO.
>> POOR THING.
>> LIKE, THEY ALL KNOW OVER
THERE.
>> THEY DO NOT.
GUY?
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> IT'S WEIRD, YOU'RE GAY,
CHADWICK'S GAY - -
I KNOW - - I HOPE YOUR PARENTS
AREN'T WATCHING.  SO WHAT
HAPPENS THERE?
I MEAN YOU'RE BOTH EMOTIONAL,
THEN ACCORDING TO THIS RESEARCH.
>> YES, GREG, WELL...
[LAUGHTER]
>> WHAT'S MOST DIFFICULT, AND
THE MOST PAINFUL BREAKUPS FOR ME
HAVE BEEN ONES THAT ARE SECRET
RELATIONSHIPS AND YOU CAN'T
REALLY CONFIDE IN ANYONE ABOUT
YOUR SADNESS.
SO YOU CAN'T CALL UP A PARENT
AND SAY THE PERSON I'VE BEEN
SEEING, IT WAS GOING GREAT, AND
THEN HE HAS A SHOW AT FIVE BUT
THEN HE GOT ANOTHER SHOW AT
ELEVEN.
AND NOW HE'S JUST GHOSTED ME.
YOU CAN'T SAY THOSE THINGS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I AM SO GLAD BOTH MY PARENTS
HAVE PASSED AWAY.
IF THEY SAW THIS I MIGHT BE
RUINED.
YOU'RE PRETTY GOOD TONIGHT.
I GOTTA TELL YOU.
CHADWICK - -
>> YES, SIR?
>> OH, YOU KNOW, - -
>> GETTING BRUTALIZED.
>> I THINK BREAKUPS, IT'S
REALLY, UM, REALLY HARD ON THE
LIVER.
>> YES.
>> REALLY HARD ON THE WALLET.
LOTS OF TRIPS TO THE FREE
CLINIC.
I THINK MEN JUST BEHAVE
DIFFERENTLY IN BREAKUPS AND YOU
JUST HAVE TO SCREW EVERYONE AND
DRINK EVERYTHING AND YOU HAVE TO
GET ITOID-OUT.
I DON'T SEE WOMEN DOING THAT.
YOU GET TWO GAY GUYS THEY BREAK
UP AND THEY'VE SCREWED ALL OF
NEW YORK CITY BETWEEN THEM YOU
GOTTA GET THAT PAIN OUT.
>> SCREW THE PAIN OUT.
>> YOU DO.
>> THERE'S A SLOGAN FOR MAYOR.
ALL RIGHT.
UP NEXT, HE'LL EDIT A CLASSIC
MASTERPIECE.
YOU SATISFIED THE PC-POLICE